اعتاد أن يكون هناك محل لبيع الآيس كريم
في الزاوية حيث يلعب الأطفال في الشارع
شعورًا بأن العنف لن يضرب
هنا على الأقل ليس هكذا
بعد خمسة أيام من الغارات الجوية المتعددة التي ضربت هذا
الحي الهادئ في
مقاطعة إيطاليا مما أسفر عن مقتل العشرات من الأشخاص.
وهم الأمان
الذي ربما كان موجودًا منذ سبع سنوات حتى
الآن تم توثيق الانهيار الخطير ،
ما هو الهدف من كل
تصويرك الذي يريد إبراهيم نايف أن يعرفه لأنه
لا توجد إنسانية في هذا
العالم استجابة صامتة لتدمير سوريا
بلا قلب إلا طفل واحد من
أطفال إبراهيم الخمسة.  لقد نجا ، إنها مجرد
ذكريات الآن ، قُتلت جميع أفراد الأسرة المجاورة
النازحة من أماكن أخرى ،
سبعة منهم قُتلوا أيضًا ، وكان
الناشط الإعلامي حميد أحمد
يبلغ من العمر 20 عامًا فقط ممرضًا ومستجيبًا أولًا من خلال
تدريبه على دور لعبه في مسقط رأسه في
حلب قبل أن تقتل العائلة.
نزح قسرا - إد ليب عندما تولى النظام
السلطة عندما رأى أن المستجيبين
لم يكونوا هناك ألقى كاميرته جانبا
وذهب لإنقاذ فتاة صغيرة
، يخبرنا والد محمد محمد ، لكن
ضربة أخرى جاءت في قتلهما ،
بدا والديه متماسكين معًا
ولكن في حالة من الألم ، لكن فيما بعد عندما
أظهرت والدته لنا ملابس محمد ،
كسرتني في الغرفة المجاورة ، وأظهرها والده.
لنا صوره في صحتك ، إنه لا يستطيع البكاء
أمام زوجته ، لقد فعلوا كل شيء
معًا.
العنف الذي يلوح في الأفق هو آخر
معقل رئيسي متبقي للمعارضة تركيا
، تتفاوض روسيا وإيران
للتوصل ظاهريًا إلى نوع من
الاتفاق لمنع مذبحة شاملة
هنا من قبل النظام السوري
وداعميه الروس ، تمتلك تركيا
نقاط مراقبة عسكرية في المحافظة
وتسببت في حدوث  الاعتداء عليه ليب خط أحمر
تم إغلاق حدوده
وبدلاً من ذلك قال مسؤول تركي كبير إن
حكومته تضخ ملايين
الدولارات في العراق.  o تضخم مخيمات اللاجئين
قائلاً إنه يتذكر عندما كان هناك
عدد قليل من الخيام هنا وكان الباقي
مجرد بساتين زيتون والآن إذا
ألقيت نظرة وكان لديها مثل هذه الهالة
من الدوام لكل
رولينج هيلز.  تم تحويل رمي من الحدود التركية
إلى بحر
من منازل الأرواح المفقودة من منطقة توقف حماة في حلب
وفي أماكن أخرى
تضاعف عدد السكان في السنوات الأخيرة
مع وصول المزيد من السوريين ، وهي أيضًا مكان
حيث سقطت أجزاء أخرى من البلاد
تحت سيطرة الحكومة.  أعاد النظام
توطين السكان والمقاتلين المتمردين
لأولئك الذين يعيشون هنا بشكل طبيعي وتم
إعادة تعريف المنزل بشكل لا رجعة فيه ، لا يمكننا العودة إلى الوراء على
الإطلاق ،
حيث يقول إنه لا يثق
في نظام الأسد ومع عدم وجود
مكان يذهبون إليه
يشعر الكثيرون بأنهم مجرد  في انتظار
تنفيذ حكم الإعدام عليهم
أروى دامون ستنة تعترف بالمشاكل